There are many ways to answer this question, and
I really just wanted you to try and come up
with one on your own. One possible explanation would
be that, although both individuals have the same genetics for
these eight factors. One individual, woman two, suffered more
spontaneous mutations from her environment, while the other had fewer.
This means she had more repair to do and couldn't
get it done as efficiently as woman one. Another explanation
could be that woman two had additional genetic
factors that damaged the repair mechanisms or encouraged
tumor growth or maybe woman one had genetic
factors that actually helped protect her. The bottom
line is these would be differences for other
unknown genetic factors between the two women. Most
likely the answer to this question is probably
a little bit of all of these things.